this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos to use in
lectures courses presentations
professional training and more for more
information click on the link in the
description
you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with ovarian cancer
this video will help you understand how
to manage it
the ovaries are two glands in a woman's
pelvis they produce eggs for
reproduction and make hormones
ovarian cancer is a disease in which
cancer cells grow out of control in your
ovaries
treatment for ovarian cancer may remove
or destroy the cancer
after treatment it's very important to
have a follow-up care plan
this includes going to all follow-up
appointments
your doctor will want to check to see if
the cancer has returned
and check for health problems resulting
from treatment
you will likely need to see your doctor
often after your treatment
ask about what kind of schedule you can
expect
if you are on any medications continue
to take them as prescribed by your
doctor
take note of any side effects and tell
your doctor
if you had surgery on your ovaries or
other treatments follow any instructions
you were given
you may also need to make some of the
following healthy lifestyle changes
don't smoke and limit how much alcohol
you drink both of these activities may
increase your risk of cancer
eat a healthy diet with more fruits
vegetables and whole grains
a healthy diet may reduce the risk of
your cancer coming back
become physically active daily exercise
and activities can help you feel better
it is important to speak with your
doctor before starting an exercise plan
or making lifestyle changes
keep in mind that some cancer treatments
can make you feel very tired
ask your doctor what you can do to help
you feel less tired
knowing you have cancer can be
overwhelming you may have worries about
things like your condition and how it
affects your family
treatments and hospital stays medical
bills
and your job
fortunately there are ways to cope with
this
talk to your health care team they can
help you find the support that's right
for you
the following sources of support can
help you cope with your concerns
social
workers church leaders
counselors
and support groups
talk to your doctor if you have any
questions about your treatment plan
medications or lifestyle changes to help
you manage ovarian cancer